[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX DESYATYKH: We
started in 2008.
Since that time, we've
made more than 100 apps
for start-ups or large
enterprise companies.
While working on
all those apps, I
guess we've done pretty
much every mistake possible.
So we know all the dos and
don'ts in mobile developments.
ARTHUR SAKHAROV: The
primary goal of our company
is to have the best
engineers possible in Russia.
We work within
Android platforms.
We use Google
products every day.
And it's great for us
to be in connection
with the engineers that actually
develop the products that we
use every day.
To work with the
Google agency program
was important because it
helps us to make secure apps.
It helps us make beautiful apps.
It helps us make
reliable apps that suits
a client's business needs.
MAX DESYATYKH: Being
a leading company
is very hard because you
have to run fast just to stay
in your current position.
As for Russia, we are
very well-known agency,
but overseas we're
not very well-known.
And the agency program
helps us prove that we
can build great products.
ARTHUR SAKHAROV:
[? Promsvyazbank, ?]
when it was first released, it
was one of the first banking
apps to have material
design in it.
We also used Firebase
and the recent releases
to get the analytics,
send messages, control
the response of the
app, which can be shown
and which can be turned off.
We actually were on
the training in London
with all the Firebase stuff.
It's quicker to get all the
answers in a personal way.
IGOR VOLOSHIN: Being a
certified company in Russia
means a lot to our
clients because we
can share with them the
long-term strategies
of the platforms and offer them
great features that are only
coming to the platform.
MAX DESYATYKH: When
we build useful apps,
we want not to change the
entire life of a person,
we just want to make it slightly
better, to save some time,
to be more productive
in a large scale
when we build apps for
millions of users that would
make an impact in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]